el descontento estalla en antes en la
jornada número 14 de protestas contra la
Reforma pensional en Francia la policía
se enfrentó a los manifestantes
el ánimo es similar en París la capital
francesa donde también se presentaron
choques
más temprano con pancartas y banderas
miembros de sindicatos organizaron una
multitudinaria manifestación un último
pulso para presionar a los legisladores
solo días después de que se
establecieran los primeros decretos
sobre la reforma una que entre otras
medidas subirá la edad de jubilación de
los 62 a los 64 años
esta ley es injusta porque no estamos
aquí para morir en el trabajo estamos
aquí para proporcionar mano de obra por
supuesto pero como compensación tenemos
que jubilarnos con buena salud
en la manifestación se escucharon las
voces de varios de los principales
opositores al presidente
como la del líder del partido
izquierdista Francia en sumisa
debate por hacer en la asamblea nacional
lo vamos a llevar hasta el último minuto
hasta el último Segundo si ganamos
habremos ganado si perdemos la lucha
seguirá más al sur en burdeos los
sindicatos hicieron eco de los reclamos
contra la reforma seis meses de lucha es
mucho tiempo los franceses todavía no
están de acuerdo ya no vivimos en
democracia y Seguiremos luchando porque
no quiero jubilarme a los 64 eso sigue
siendo un no a pesar de los pedidos
desde diferentes partes del territorio
galo el presidente se opuso a hacer
comentarios los sindicatos prometen más
protestas Mientras que el gobierno no
cede a la presión en